Super Ball is coming up this weekend and
some of the big advertisers have already
started teasing the ads they'll be
showing during the game you can see them
online have you seen some of these I
have yeah yeah well one advertiser
that's been getting a lot of attention
this is true is planter's peanuts I
don't know if you heard about this but
they are getting rid of their famous
mascot mr. peanut yeah getting rid of
mr. peanut yeah it's a kind of a guess I
don't know I don't know why they made
this choice but I do know one person
who's not very happy about it
we managed to get the only interview
with them please welcome the former
corporate mascot of Pirates
[Music]
hey how you doing there mr. peanut how
am i doing how do you think I'm doing
you idiot they kicked me to the curb Hey
alright well that's what I'm notorious
alright alright
your mouth isn't moving much so so I
can't move it it's just a smile but
trust me I'm not smiling okay right I
got it got it okay like the shell of
piss okay alright so you weren't on
board with the decision is that right it
wasn't on board at all of course not
look they said that they was looking to
freshen things up for the new year I
says fine I'll get out there I'll do
some raps maybe some breakdancing some
popping and locking some rollerblading
you know maybe I'll twerk with LaToya
Jackson whatever the teens are into I
don't know teens are not into any of
that [ __ ] you just said no no no one's
done that in 50 years and I I guess
that's not what they meant anyway right
yeah you damn right they just want to be
out they Pearl Harbor okay that's a
little extreme they think that's extreme
it was exactly the same as Pearl Harbor
now it was that it's a ridiculous
compare what am I was not is the same I
can't think of one difference between I
can think of our differences between
your firing and Pearl Harbor oh we don't
know anything about a history I guess
all right well anyway you worked them a
long time weren't a long time I gave
them a hundred and four of the best
years of my line out you've been with
him on him for years that's a long time
not long enough though I was two weeks
away from collecting my pension Melissa
what are you gonna do you know how it is
the cashews run Hollywood I don't I
don't think you can say shoes you know
you get it right no oh no no maybe you
can't you get out say it no no I'm not
sure I think all nuts are alike in the
same so let's leave it at that is the
furthest thing alright alright
well mr. peanut I'm just sorry to hear
that this was not a mutual agreement no
it was a real Boonton yes and I don't
get it either because I was always a
complete professional I mean sure you
know maybe I offended a few snowflakes
with my honesty here and there yeah but
listen I'd like to see you resist making
off-color jokes when all of America
loves eating in that's that I got it
yeah yeah cuz ate the nuts yes yeah yeah
yeah look some unflattering things are
gonna be coming out about me in the
press
oh really oh yeah well that's what they
do you know but I just want to say none
of that is true I never touched the Land
O'Lakes girl okay well anyway I mean I
thought like everybody else no one else
thought about it he thinks about no they
did mr. peanut no one needed to know I
do have to ask what would you be doing
now but don't worry Conan I got I got
irons in the fire I just did the Joe
Rogan Podge oh I love that podcast very
good yeah listen here's a spoiler but
you might see me on the new season of
the masked singer yeah I think I know
where hey wonder which one you are about
surprise you yeah all right I also did
one of those sexy dating reality shows
it's called Skye's eyelids
scuz island all right that's Netflix
Ukraine okay
listen I'm excited to announce my first
new EDM
that's great you are looking at the new
face of baby blocker condom okay
autozone and risk stops across America
all right that's enough that's a
terrible idea and I I think I hate you
now that's a coated it's a money-back
guarantee if you catch crabs crabs I
want to hear a horrible horrible night
these condoms come regular or Chow I
think we're all out of time for you mr.
peanut thank you very much for being
here
you're terrible